animation can be a very labor-intensive
process and 3D computer animation can
take huge amounts of time to render this
means that animated movies can have
hundreds of people as part of the
production crew or working on different
aspects of the project to get it out in
a reasonable time frame a good example
is The Lion King around 600 animators
artists and technicians were involved in
their production from misconception
until they hit Cinema screens meanwhile
the CGI is Frozen 2 from 2019 had a team
that was 800 people strong working on
the project Spider-Man across the
spiderverse puts all of these numbers to
shame the new film had more than 1 000
people as part of the crew with Phil
Lord and Chris Miller selling deadline
that it has the largest crew of any
animated movie ever made significantly
more than worked on the first film